herzlich willkommen ZDF heute live heute
eine andere Sendung eine etwas andere
denn wir berichten live aus herson in
der Ukraine wir berichten aus dem Gebiet
dass seit zwei Tagen seit mehr als zwei
Tagen überflutet wird weil der Staudamm
der kachowka Staudamm gebrochen ist und
wir stehen hier auch vor der Wasserlinie
die ist etwas weiter hinter uns und
nehmen euch heute mit live in der
Sendung ich werde auch später nicht
alleine sein habe einen freiwilligen
nämlich hier ein Freiwilligen aus
Deutschland heute in Essen gab es Besuch
von Präsident selensky der war auch in
der Region um sich ein Bild selbst vor
Ort von der Katastrophe zu machen
besuchte hier das örtliche Krankenhaus
dankte den Helfern forderte natürlich
auch gleichzeitig mehr Unterstützung für
die Region und noch dazu was heute auch
Thema war und auch jetzt in der Sendung
Thema sein wird es gab Beschuss heute
den Tag über wir haben uns auch in
Sicherheit bringen müssen dass er hier
jetzt zu Anfang der Sendung gesagt falls
es also natürlich noch mal dazu kommen
sollte endet diese Sendung auch sehr
erprobt aber jetzt wollen wir es erstmal
versuchen so lange es gerade
einigermaßen ruhig ist stellt gerne
Fragen direkt in den Stream oder
schreibt sie per Mail dann kann ich die
auch mitnehmen ihr habt eben hoffentlich
auch schon Bilder gesehen von den
Menschen die hier vor Ort helfen das
sind viele mutige freiwillige und einer
von ihnen ist jetzt bei mir ist sogar
ein freiwilliger aus Deutschland ist es
Nils Tal er ist Feuerwehrmann eigentlich
aus Nürnberg hallo Nils ganz toll dass
du heute da bist vielen Dank guten Abend
Nils kannst du uns erzählen über die
letzten zwei Tage wo du hier am Einsatz
bist was sind deine Herausforderungen
und wie ist die Lage vor Ort die Lage
ist dass wir zufällig Equipment haben zu
wenig Boote zu wenig Motorboote vor
allem wir haben zu wenig warthosen also
Matrosen wir haben zu wenig
Taschenlampen ja es mangelt an vielen
Sachen also mir dann empfehlen an vielen
Gegenständen die notwendig sind und für
wasserrettungsequipment
sind heute in unter Beschuss gekommen
während der Rettung das gab es auch
Verletzte unter den Rettern wir haben
uns dann zwischenzeitlich in einem der
Häuser unterbringen können bis wir dann
bis Überschuss weniger wurde mir dann
eben wieder zurück an Sofa kommen
konnten ich habe dich heute getroffen
dich heute kennengelernt ich habe Nils
getroffen da ist er gerade ins Boot
gestiegen also zum Einsatz direkt
gefahren und unmittelbar kurz danach war
der Beschuss und dann hast du dich in
Sicherheit gebracht konntet ihr dann
heute überhaupt noch Menschen retten in
der Beschuss der ging ja über mehrere
Stunden also ab dem Augenblick wo die wo
das der Beschuss intensiver wurde wo die
Artillerie Granaten relativ nah
eingeschlagen sind konnten wir nichts
mehr machen die ganze Zeit im Haus
praktisch versteckt sozusagen und dann
durch gewartet bis sie sehen weniger
wurde und danach hat das Militär
übernommen
und was sind sonst natürlich auch noch
Probleme mit denen ihr hier zu kämpfen
habt ich meine das Wasser das ist
gestiegen stetig gestiegen viele
Menschen sitzen hier noch in den Häusern
fest was in was für Situationen kommt
ihr wenn ihr dann also zum
Rettungsversuch geht wie findet wie
findet so eine Rettung statt also das
ist in der Regel eine völlige
Improvisation man kommt dann das Haus
hin und dann steht da entweder jemand
drin der gehen möchte oder eben jemand
der nicht geben möchte das ist dann
immer erst ne kurze Debatte dass man
dann entweder jemand mitnimmt oder eben
auch nicht und ansonsten haben wir eben
noch die Tiere manche Menschen geben
auch ihre Tiere mit oder bleiben selbst
zu Hause geben das hier mit ab und wir
fahren das dann reicht ja schon super
also das ist das ist ein provisation
jedes Mal wir da gibt's keine Rezepte
dafür
eine Improvisation und eben auch weniger
Helfer vor Ort es gab auch Kritik es gab
Kritik von Präsident selenski wir haben
einen O2 dazu indem wir mal gemeinsam
reinhören und danach drüber sprechen
wir brauchen internationale
Organisationen wie das Internationale
Komitee vom Roten Kreuz die sich sofort
den Rettungsoperation anschließen um den
Leuten im besetzen Teil der Sonne Region
zu helfen jeder Mensch der dort stirbt
zeigt die Schwächen der internationalen
Ordnung auf und das internationale
Organisation vergessen haben wie sie
leben retten
wenn der Präsident kritisiert das zu
wenig internationale Hilfe vor Ort ist
wie empfindest du das jetzt bist du
einer der wenigen internationalen der
hier ist also ich hatte im Verlauf des
Tages oder letzten zwei Tage hier viel
Menschen aus dem Ausland getroffen die
nicht Presse waren also sind nicht viele
da
was glaubst du woran liegt das ich denke
das ist eine rechtliche Sache wir haben
in Deutschland oder auch in anderen
europäischen Ländern eine rechtliche
Lage das ist schwer ist jemanden in
einem Kriegsgebiet zu senden oder
beziehungsweise dass da eine
Versicherung noch das trägt wenn etwas
passiert und ich denke das macht sehr
viele schwierig das wäre eine Aufgabe
für die Politik wir haben auch noch
einen weiteren Ton den wir dazu mal
zusammen anhören wollen die Kollegen in
Deutschland haben den Präsident des
Technischen Hilfswerks dazu interviewt
und auch daran werden wir jetzt mal
zusammen rein
das jetzt an bestimmten Organisationen
gedrückt Kritik geübt wird kann ich so
nicht beurteilen ich kenne
beispielsweise nicht das Engagement des
Roten Kreuzes in der Ukraine die Frage
ist auch immer ist meinte er das Rote
Kreuz in der Ukraine oder meinte
internationale Hilfe
Leistungskapazitäten die zur Verfügung
gestellt werden können und da erinnere
ich nur aus an die Situation die vor Ort
herrlich nämlich das Rettungskräfte die
vor Ort tätig sind unter anderem auch
unter Beschuss liegen wenn diese
Informationen zutreffen dann ist es
natürlich eine besondere Sicherheitslage
die den Einsatz von internationalen
nicht nationalen Kräften sehr sehr
erschwert
eine besondere Sicherheitslage die den
Einsatz erschwert wie gehst du damit um
also unter Beschuss zu geraten das ist
ja keine Situation die man irgendwie aus
Deutschland nur ansatzweise kennt
ich versuche rational zu bleiben wenn
ich das Geräusch der Artillerie höre man
merkt das nach einer Weile ist das
ausgehend oder dass das incoming wie
nahe ist es dran dementsprechend verhält
man sich dann auch also kann man sich
anders verhalten als wenn ich
beispielsweise merke dass es sehr nah
dran ist dann warte ich erstmal weil
möglicherweise noch eine zweite kommt
oder es ist eben so dass das Natalie
Duell stattfindet also erstmal sitzen
bleiben hinter der dicke Wand am besten
in der zweite gewendet und dann warten
ich habe in eure Kommentare auch mal
reingeschaut und möchte natürlich jetzt
auch eure Fragen hier stellen und zwar
fragt sich David Beck bei Youtube ob es
denn die Möglichkeit gibt vor Ort zu
helfen wir haben ja jetzt schon gehört
gelernt du bist einer der wenigen der
hier ist du bist aber hier eben aus
Deutschland was würdest Du darauf
antworten es gibt die Möglichkeit zu
helfen ja
aber jetzt da schließt sich die zweite
Frage an von Louis bei Youtube der sich
fragt wie lange du schon vor Ort bist
und wie lange du denn Zeit hast zu
bleiben weil du bist ja gerade hier ganz
besonders also beschreib uns das doch
mal ich war jetzt ungefähr einen Monat
in Konstantin bei bachmut danach bin ich
kurz nach Kiel und aufgrund dessen dass
hier die Lage mit dem Stau dann war bin
ich nach Herz angefahren
es gibt noch weitere Fragen und zwar
fragt Jette lizek wie kann man die
Hilfsaktionen unterstützen an dieser
Stelle würde ich natürlich auch darauf
hinweisen und vielleicht können wir die
jetzt auch mal zeigen auf unsere
Spendentafel vom Aktionsbündnis
Katastrophenhilfe die hilft also den
Menschen hier vor Ort natürlich
finanziell den Menschen hier im
Überschwemmungsgebiet also wenn ihr das
auch tun möchtet dann könnt ihr unter
dem Stichwort ZDF Nothilfe Ukraine
Spenden die IBAN
de65100 400 600-100 400 600 aber ich
spiele natürlich auch die Frage noch mal
an dich zurück denn wie kann man die
Hilfsaktion unterstützen hast du da noch
mehr Tipps
ich kann jemanden auffordern etwas zu
tun aber ich denke wenn man sich das
hier ansieht wenn man sich die Bilder
seit einem Jahr anguckt dann weiß
eigentlich oder was zu tun ist
was war für dich heute ein Moment der
dich gepackt hat wo du es geschafft hast
wo du jemanden retten konntest war was
war das für eine Situation und wie fühlt
sich das dann für dich natürlich auch an
wenn dann sowas mal gelingt also sind
jede Menge Menschen die wir mit mit
verschiedenen Boden praktisch aus den
Häusern geholt haben und hierher
gebracht haben am schönsten war der
Augenblick was war der erste Augenblick
mit dem kleinen Hund
davon habe ich auch ein Foto gesehen
dass hast du mir gezeigt das habe ich
auch bei Twitter gepostet wer sich das
anschauen mag an dieser Stelle sagen wir
jetzt erstmal vielen Dank an Nils Thal
der Tag war lang und du bist auch morgen
wieder am Einsatz vielen Dank dass du
bei uns warst
und wir können jetzt in dieser Sendung
auch noch weiter sprechen und zwar bin
ich auch nicht alleine hier sondern wir
sind hier natürlich mit einem Team und
zwar sogar mit zwei Teams unterwegs das
macht das Ganze einfacher denn hier
passiert jeden Tag so viel an so vielen
verschiedenen Orten und mein Kollege Tim
Kröger der ist schon einige Wochen hier
in der Ukraine unterwegs und war heute
eben auch außerhalb von einer Person hat
sich entlang des Flusslaufs also den Weg
in Richtung des Darms ein wenig
vorgewagt ganz einfach ist das nicht wir
können jetzt auch mit Tim sprechen über
seine Erlebnisse heute und ich hoffe er
kann mich jetzt schon hören hallo Tim
hallo Alisa
Tim kannst du uns erzählen was du
außerhalb von erlebt hast du hast hier
ja auch jetzt die letzten Tage verbracht
aber bist eben heute auch rausgegangen
wie ist die Situation vor Ort
genau wir haben ja gestern den ganzen
Tag von dem inneren Bereich von Carson
berichtet und hatten heute mal das
Bedürfnis zu gucken was eigentlich plus
aufwärts passiert also ein bisschen in
Richtung dann zu fahren also der Damm
der dann tatsächlich gebrochen ist da
sind ja auch Berichte auf dem Markt
gewesen dass sehr viele Ortschaften und
Dörfer dort unter Wasser stehen wir sind
dann hier ich glaube so eine halbe
Stunde nördlich Gefahren teilweise
mussten wir Umwege nehmen über Dörfer
weil halt die eigentliche Straße
überspült war und sind dann an einem
Dorf gekommen wo man die Überschwemmung
wirklich richtig deutlich gesehen hat
und auch in diesem Dörfern sind Menschen
die Hilfe brauchen wir haben auch einige
Hilfsorganisation gesehen die dort
Lebensmittel verteilt haben für diese
Menschen in diesem Dörfern aber das
Besondere an diesem Dörfern ist dass sie
im Grunde direkt am Fluss sitzen und sie
waren bis vor kurzem sozusagen direkt
freundlinie also direkt auf der anderen
Seite des Flusses waren die russischen
Streitkräfte und haben genau diese
Ortschaften permanent beschossen und
jetzt ist tatsächlich die Situation
eingetreten dass durch diese Wasser
diese Wassermassen die ja auch auf der
anderen Seite des Flusses sind die
russischen Kreis Streitkräfte sich
zurückgezogen haben und auf der einen
Seite ist es sozusagen etwas Positives
dass durch die Wassermassen jetzt dieser
Beschuss dieser direkte Beschuss
aufgehört hat aber jetzt kommt halt auch
gerade bei diesem Dorfbewohnern langsam
das zum Vorschein dass wir alles
befürchtet haben nämlich die
langfristigen Folgen wir haben damit
einem Anwohner gesprochen der hat uns
runter ans Wasser geführt und hat uns
gezeigt dass ein Garten überschwemmt ist
und er hat uns erzählt das ganz viele
dieser Häuser ihre Gülle reservare unten
am Fluss haben und dass diese Gülle
jetzt in dem Fluss reingeflossen ist und
er hat uns auch Wasser gezeigt was er
Leitungswasser was er abgefüllt hat und
das hat man gesehen dass das Wasser was
er gestern schon abgefüllt hat heute
bereits grün war also ganz offenbar auch
schon verschmutzt ist
das Gute ist dass man in dem Dorf
deutlich gesehen hat dass das Wasser
langsam schon zurückgeht das heißt also
ganz offenbar ist jetzt dieser dieser
Scheitelpunkt der Fluten überschritten
aber es ist wahrscheinlich wirklich so
dass jetzt mit dem Wasser was langsam
verschwindet die wirklichen Probleme
erst sichtbar werden
du hast mir auch als wir uns heute mal
ganz kurz gesehen gesprochen haben
berichtet von einer Brücke an der ihr
wart wo du auch unglaubliche Bilder
gesehen hast kannst du mir und uns davon
noch mal erzählen
genau das ist denn antoniewka-brücke das
ist eine ganz besondere besonders
wichtige verkehrsbrücke gewesen zwischen
Hassan und dem auf der anderen Seite
liegenden Ufer also eine strategische
militärisch aus strategisch sehr
wichtige Brücke die zerstört worden ist
die dann teilweise mit Pontons wieder
versucht worden ist sozusagen passierbar
zu machen es ist eine Brücke die man
ganz lange nicht filmen konnte ganz
einfach deswegen weil ja bis vor ja
eigentlich drei vier Tagen der Gang
vorne an den Nico also in den Fluss an
die an die Wasserfront sozusagen
lebensgefährlich war ganz einfach weil
auf der anderen Seite die russischen
Streitkräfte saßen und auch unter
anderem russische Heckenschützen
deswegen war es für uns Medien
eigentlich nie möglich mal zu gucken was
wirklich mit dieser Brücke ist und heute
konnten wir einmal kurz dran
vorbeifahren und es ist wirklich so dass
er völlig zerstört worden ist und ähm ja
also das ist natürlich der spannend für
uns gewesen einmal zu sehen
das ist eigentlich alles was ich dazu
sagen kann
vielen Dank für deine Eindrücke und wir
sprechen und sehen dich natürlich auch
jetzt in den nächsten Tagen auf den
Plattform des ZDF wieder vielen Dank
und wir können an dieser Stelle jetzt
auch noch eine schalte nach Deutschland
machen ihr wisst dass wir auch gerne für
euch diese Situation analysieren und
einordnen auch gerade die militärische
Lage hier einordnen und bei mir ist
jetzt eben auch jemand den ihr sicher
schon gut kennt wenn ihr dieses Streams
regelmäßig verfolgt bei mir ist Ex
Nato-General Egon Rams schönen guten
Abend Herr Rams schön dass sie auch
heute wieder bei uns sind
lassen Sie uns mal auf die auslöser
dieses Dammbruchs sprechen drei Tage
sind jetzt ungefähr vergangen seitdem
und es gibt natürlich viele Fragen wie
wo was das passiert ist wie das
passieren konnte und vielleicht können
Sie für uns jetzt ein bisschen besser
einordnen wie das passieren konnte ist
der dann von früheren Treffern
beschädigt gewesen eine Theorie eine
andere Idee Theorie natürlich der
Sprengung und da gibt es also viele
offene Fragen nach wie vor was weiß man
dazu heute mehr
also ich möchte gerne dazu beitragen
diese offenen Fragen zu beantworten aber
das ist eine schwierige Situation dass
das bisher an Informationen haben aus
nachrichtendienstlichen Bereichen und
von dem was wir ein aufklärungsergebnis
haben gibt kein eindeutigen Hinweis
darauf es ist seit heute auch noch eine
dritte Spekulation im Gange der
Kaufer See hat ein sehr hohen
Wasserstand gehabt das heißt es gibt die
ersten Experten die auch davon reden
dass es möglicherweise sogar ich sag mal
einfacher Dammbruch ohne irgendwelche
militärischen oder springen Einwirkungen
oder sonstige gewesen ist von daher das
ist alles offen man muss dann ein
bisschen nicht sagt das mal mit den
Folgen
rechnen oder die Folgen beurteilen wer
hat von diesem Dammbruch Vorteile oder
wer hat keine Vorteile ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen dass Präsident selenski
oder der ukrainischen Generalstab eine
Situation herbeigeführt hat wo auf
beiden Seiten des Depot sich Ortschaften
man spricht auf der ukrainischen Seite
von etwa 80 Eigenschaften durch diese
Flutwelle geflutet werden und damit
Einwohner der Ukraine in diesem
nördlichen Teil des nepro praktisch
gezwungen werden ihren Lebensraum ihrer
Ortschaften zu verlassen das Risiko
eingegangen wird dass Menschen umkommen
wenn Sie erlauben werfe ich mal einen
kleinen Blick zurück in die Geschichte
in das Jahr 1941
im Jahr 1941 hat der russische NKWD
angesichts des deutschen Angriffs weiter
nördlicher ebenfalls mal einen Staudamm
gesprengt um auf diese Art und Weise das
Vorrücken der deutschen Soldaten zu
erschweren oder sogar zu verhindern das
heißt die Art und Weise dieses zu machen
ist durchaus keine neue und sie hat
damals zwar nicht geholfen sie wird
möglicherweise heute auch nicht helfen
aber sie wird sicherlich auch auf die
Planung der Ukraine im unteren Bereich
Einfluss nehmen mit Blick auf die gegen
Offensive denn der Raum der jetzt
geflutet worden ist ist damit für die
gegen Offensive auf Wochen
möglicherweise auf Monate nicht mehr
nutzbar das heißt die Vorteile von
diesem Dammbruch liegen auf der
russischen Seite von daher ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass es von
russischer Seite her verursacht worden
ist relativ gut aber ich wiederhole noch
einmal es gibt keine endgültigen
Erkenntnisse wer es war oder ob es
möglicherweise sogar eine normale
Ursache eines Dammbruchs war
lassen Sie uns noch mal eben sie haben
es eben angesprochen auf die
Auswirkungen auf die Offensive eingehen
es gibt dazu eine Frage im Stream von
Val deware er oder sie möchte wissen wie
beeinflusst das gerade die anlaufende
Gegenoffensive der Ukraine sie haben
gesagt das verlangsamt Sie also es gibt
keine Möglichkeit der Fluss passierung
da können sie für uns dann noch mal ein
bisschen ins Detail gehen
also die überfluteten Gebiete jetzt muss
man wieder auf die Fahrzeuge die
Gefechtsfahrzeuge gucken die
normalerweise bei solchen gegen
Angriffen eingesetzt werden das sind
Radfahrzeuge das sind aber auch
panzerkampfpanzer Schützenpanzer
Artilleriegeschütze und der Boden der
jetzt ich sage mal durch das Wasser
durch die Flutwelle entsprechend
durchdringt worden ist wird für Wochen
möglicherweise für Monate solche
Fahrzeuge nicht tragen die würden dort
wie in einem Sumpfgebiet versinken und
das könnte dann dazu führen dass im
Prinzip für einen möglichen Gegenangriff
eine gegen Offensive der Ukraine in
diesem Raum südlich des Staudamms das
Gelände nicht mehr geeignet ist und dies
wie gesagt über eine längere Zeit wenn
das der Plan der Ukraine war unter dem
Gesichtspunkt dass die Ukraine ja einige
Male gesagt hat man möchte die Krim auch
zurückerobern dann ist diese Möglichkeit
in diesem Raum in diesem Bereich zurzeit
nicht mehr gegeben schlicht und einfach
formuliert das heißt wenn das so warm
muss die Ukraine anfangen um zu planen
was denn heute Zeit kosten wird
zum Schluss noch die Frage wie schätzen
Sie das ein dass jetzt hier vielleicht
auf natürlich durch diese dieses Ausmaß
diese Katastrophe diese Flut das jetzt
auch hier einfach sehr viele ukrainische
Kräfte gebunden werden die vielleicht
dann an anderer Stelle bei anderen
Angriffen anderen offensiven fehlen
schauen wir einmal noch ein bisschen
weiter weg hier von dieser Region
also wenn die Russe die ukrainische
Seite zur Unterstützung der Bevölkerung
dort Streitkräfte in größerem Umfang
ukrainische Streitkräfte einsetzen dann
stehen naturgemäß diese Streitkräfte an
anderer Stelle nicht mehr zur Verfügung
das heißt wenn man einen Angriff bachmut
ist die letzten Tage wieder im Gespräch
gewesen oder der Bereich dann jetzt
überhaupt wenn man in diesem Bereich
angreifen will und Kräfte dafür
vorgesehen hat die sich möglicherweise
jetzt in andere Art und Weise sag mal
bei einer Art Katastropheneinsatz
nützlich machen müssen dann dürfte an
solche Angriff da oben irgendwie
ebenfalls nicht mehr über genügend
Kräfte verfügen wobei ich das nicht
glaube denn die Ukraine wird keine
Kräfte oben aus dem Raum drin jetzt oder
du kannst in den Süden verlegen um dort
bei der Katastrophe helfen zu können da
hat möglicherweise auch trotz der
notwendigen Katastrophenhilfe das was
die Ukraine vor hat dann für den Staat
für den Generalstab für das
Verteidigungsministerium und auch für
den Präsidenten durchaus eine höhere
Priorität
ich habe doch noch eine letzte Frage die
ich Ihnen gerne stellen möchte heranz
und zwar gab es da Berichte in der Nacht
hat die ukrainische Armee nach
russischen Angaben versucht die Front in
der Region saporisha zu durchbrechen und
die Frage an Sie versucht die Ukraine da
jetzt erst recht vorzustoßen oder
versucht sie da weiter die russische
Seite zu testen was ist ihre
Einschätzung
also im
Rahmens ist das A von der Flut oder von
dem Dammbruch zunächst mal nicht
betroffen der Wasserstand im See
insgesamt wird sinken
saporisha ist ein Bereich den die
Ukrainer gerne in die Hand bekommen
möchten und der dann möglicherweise auch
die Gelegenheit bietet sich auch mit dem
Kernkraftwerk südlich des kakowska
Staudamms wieder entsprechend zu oder
sie ist wieder entsprechend zu
beschäftigen beziehungsweise dieses
Kernkraftwerk in die eigene Hand zu
bekommen vielleicht auch da noch eine
kleine Anmerkung dabei das kein
Kraftwerk welches Jahr das Wasser diese
Stausee ist benötigt um die
entsprechende Kühlung für die sechs
Reaktoren selbst wenn sie nicht mehr in
Betrieb sind sicher stellt sicher zu
stellen das klappt zurzeit noch da ist
keine unmittelbare Gefahr aber wenn der
Wasserstand
auf einen Level von unter Elfmetern
fällt dann wird auch diese Kühlung
schwierig werden obwohl das
Kernkraftwerk dort einen relativ großen
hat in dem sich große Mengen von
Kühlwasser befinden also auch das ist
ein Punkt über den man längerfristig mit
Blick auf den Wasserstand des stause ist
auch noch mal nachdenken muss
ein Schätzungen von Ex Nato-General Egon
Rams vielen Dank auch heute wieder dafür
und wir sind auch weiter für euch mit
dem ZDF unterwegs in Restaurant in der
Region in der Ukraine und Berichten für
euch weiter in den nächsten Tagen ihr
seid immer aktuell informiert bei ZDF
heute danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit und
tschüss